well the sandy valley fire continues to
bring this evening southwest of the
valley good evening to you thank you for
joining us at five i'm brian loftis
and i'm denise valdez the sandy valley
fire burning just a few miles from
mountain springs south of highway 160
not too far from mount podesy joe
moeller is live there with the latest
we've also learned more about the cause
of this fire joe
just a short time ago we learned that
the cause of this fire was target
shooting law enforcement just came down
with that a few hours ago
now this looks a lot different than it
did 24 hours ago when we saw that plume
of smoke from las vegas and perramp
looks a lot calmer today but
firefighters are still out here
trying to get containment on this place
so far it has burned 1500 acres
crews are still working on containment
throughout the day we have watched
tankers drop retardant on the fire
team burning on the hillside yesterday
this sparked around 1 30
and that plume of smoke was easy to spot
now kirsten conner from the bureau of
land management says
law enforcement determined a bullet
hitting a rock and dry vegetation to be
the cause
she says there are target restrictions
in the area
human-caused fires used to be about half
the fires that were started in southern
nevada
it's definitely trending a lot higher to
human cost fires
and for blm for fires that are started
on beyond managed public land the vast
majority are unfortunately caused by
target shooting
no structures have burned crews are
working to stop the blaze from moving
north towards mountain springs and now
back out here live you're taking another
look at that hillside you can kind of
make out the retardant that's
just surrounding where this fire has
burned just a moment ago i watched on
the fire truck that said
it was from utah that was just arriving
here to the scene now every evening
fire crews they assess
we'll be out here throughout the weekend
to make sure they do get some
containment on this blaze
the next update regarding this fire is
later on this evening around 8 o'clock
reporting live near mountain springs joe
mullen 8 news now